تجسس في العالم وكشف عن جزء منها عبر
تسريبات ادوارد شنودن وتسريبات ملفات
البانتاجون هذه التسريبات بينت ان وكاله
الامن القوميه الامريكي تجمع كميات هائله
من الاتصالات من جميع انحاء العالم وانها
تتجسس على الاصدقاء والاعداء على حد سواء
وفي الوقت الحاضر تتعاون الولايات المتحده
بانتظام في جمع المعلومات الاستخباريه
بشان الصين مع حلفاء لها مثل استراليا
ونيوزيلندا كما انها ترسل طائره استطلاع
خاصه بها قرب المجال الجوي الصيني الصحيفه
اعتبرت ان اي معلومات قد يجمعها الصينيون
في كوبا لن تكون بذات القدر مقارنه بما
تجمعه الولايات المتحده عن الصين وانه لا
يجب ان يكون سببا لنسف الجهود المبذوله
لتحسين العلاقات مع تكين
اخيرا وبخصوص العلاقات مع كوبا قالت
واشنطن بوست ان الولايات المتحده ربما
دفعت كوبا لاحضان الصين بالعقوبات
المفروضه منذ اكثر من 60 عاما عليها ومع
مواجهه كوبا ازمه اقتصاديه حاده كانت
مليارات بوكين امرا لا يمكن لهافانا ان
ترفضه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات